oui surtout qu'on a on a vraiment
découvert des choses ce matin on a
découvert ce matin on était pratiquement
les seuls à ignorer l'existence de ces
étranges personnages imaginaires qui
sont venues du japon qui fascinent les
enfants qui on l'a dit et qui parfois
inquiète les parents oui et nous avons
découvert que les cartes représentant
ces drôles de bestioles comme pikachu et
rondoudou ont littéralement envahi les
cours de récréation c'est un véritable
troc qui s'est organisée alors pour bien
comprendre ce phénomène à pierre
emmanuel luneau et sophie n'est ni honte
enquêter dans une école de rouen pokémon
voilà en quelques mois les cours de
récréation été littéralement envahis par
ce nouveau phénomène venu du japon
les enfants en oublierait presque le
traditionnel ballon de foot ni de plaies
et des petits personnages comme cela il
en existe plus de 150 les pokémon
abréviation de monstres de poche se
décline sur plusieurs supports carte à
jouer jeux vidéo ou même peluche en fait
quand on a rattrapé un difficile de s'en
séparer et à ossun je les connais tous
les 150 ch oui
quant au phénomène de mémoire pour
retenir tous les noms des personnages
des reconnaître on va on aimerait bien
voir ça en conjugaison en mathématiques
du côté des fournisseurs on se frotte
les mains
le phénomène n'a vraiment débuté en
france qu'à l'automne dernier mais déjà
près d'un million de jeux vidéo ont été
écoulés en six mois les cartes sinon les
recevants par camions circulent toutes
les nuits mettons en place le matin
avant l'ouverture et ensuite toutes les
demi-heures un travailleur en poussage
permanent de façon à garder une
disponibilité maximale du produit n'ont
plus du tout on n'a plus du tout cartes
pokémon sa porte comme des petits pains
dans dix minutes on les reçoit pendant
la plus chère du tout
au japon où le jeu est né il ya quatre
ans le phénomène prend aujourd'hui une
ampleur considérable
les pokémon sont partout et lors du
lancement du 151e personnages de la
série
les forces de l'ordre ont dû intervenir
pour maîtriser la foule
aujourd'hui pokémon au niveau mondial
représente un chiffre d'affaires global
de 7 milliards de dollars
ce chiffre d'affaires est en progression
constante puisque il y à un lancement en
europe qui n'a que six mois alors qu'aux
états unis ça fait déjà deux ans
l'invasion ont planifié donc mais est
elle vraiment du goût de tous les
parents je connais j'en ai entendu
parler mais on a lutté contre dorothée à
l'époque de dorothée aujourd'hui on
essaie de lutter contre les pokémon de
cette lutte on ne sait pas encore qui va
l'emporter en attendant aux dernières
nouvelles le cours du pokémon est à la
hausse pour vous parler du cours de la
bourse je vais me permettre de vous
offrir h et de pikachu donc c'est le
héros préférés bien les enfants et je
remercie le risque qui nous a cédé
pendant quelques instants c'est horrifié
objet voilà ces objets si précieux sam à
la nation du coup les cours de la bourse
alors